lentement péniblement oussam al colak
revient à la maison du moins ce qu'il en
reste
là où s'élevait il ya un peu plus d'une
semaine
l'immeuble de cinq étages construit par
son grand père ne reste plus qu'une
tonnes de gravats quatre décennies
d'histoire familiale réduite en
poussière
la nuit du 16 mai tout le clan un cola
qui s'étaient réfugiées ici pour se
mettre à l'abri de l'intense campagne de
bombardements les bombes tomber si
proche dit-il que la maison a tremblé
comme à 1h30 du matin
il entend une énorme déflagration et
tout s'effondre
miraculé oussama n'a que des blessures
mineures mais quand il sort des
décombres il prend conscience de
l'ampleur du désastre travers certains
enfants à charge
c'est dit c'est dit avoir perdu son
grand-père sa grand-mère sa mère de ses
frères des cousins l'or en forme
une liste sans femme entend 22 personnes
fauchées
on dit que la vie doit continuer disons
que tout passe remettre d'avoir faire du
temps proche
et cette tragédie est loin d'être un cas
isolé car dans la même rue la même nuit
au même moment où s'effondrait la maison
d alcool ac 7 immeubles s'écroulent est
lui aussi est sous les décombres 23
personnes dans 16 membres de la même
famille la rue al warda était auparavant
une artère commerciale très animé de
gaza ce n'est plus aujourd'hui qu'un
champ de ruines
et ce n'est pas terminé au milieu du
chaos
une opération de sauvetage s'organisent
pour tenter de récupérer ce qui peut
encore l'être de sept immeubles
fragilisés par l'explosion d'une bombe
juste devant malgré la trêve
même si les bombardements ont cessé gaza
n'a pas fini de s'effondrer
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
gaza